Schauen wir mal jetzt jetzt müsste es ja eigentlich also jetzt habe ich neu gestartet mehr kann ich jetzt beim besten wille nicht machen
So mal gucken wie es jetzt ist
passt
Das ist ok
Passt das da und jetzt?
Passt, okay gut
Okay, was auch immer das teil für ein problem hatte
Keine ahnung
Aber dann, war weiter so fischer kann es mich wieder entweiten
Hallo moin moin leute ich stream schon ihr habt jetzt gerade erst die benachrichtigung gekriegt
Aber ich spiele schon eine ganze weile bloß mein soundverkratz nicht zum grund deswegen habe ich es viel neu gestartet
Provider telekom und unity media gerade über telekom
Eichenwald
Es gibt ja ein paar englische also englischsprachige casters die schaffen es mittlerweile eichenwald eichenwald auszusprechen
Wobei das hört hört ich denn eher so wie eichenwald eichenwald
Aber die kriegen es hin
Na dass ich zwei provider hat hat historische gründe
Ich hatte die ganze zeit unity media weil es bei mir nur dsl 16.000 gegeben hat
Und jetzt hat die telekom ausgebaut und jetzt gibt es vdsl 100 dann habe ich für vdsl 100 geholt aber unity media läuft noch
Ja sandro das war mal
Da habe ich quasi dann über telekom also ich hatte ja dieses dsl 16 k vorher auch
weil halt telefonanschluss
Auch also mit dsl 16.000 nicht wirklich viel billiger gewesen ist
Dann habe ich quasi gespielt über dsl 16
K also sprich mit diesem ein mbit upload war komplett von arschloch zum spielen vollkommen ausreichen
Und gestreamt habe ich über unity media mit 5 mbit upload das ist jetzt natürlich mit 40 mbit viel besser
crosshair kann ich dir zeigen
crosshair wo ist es
Wenn es dich interessiert
Die an so wie das habe ich getroffen
Besser verpiss dich der winston ist der lebensmüde oder was
Der winston ist lebensmüde
Ich glaube das geht wieder ja scheinbar wieder zu gehen
Es ist halt echt schwierig ist hier gerade was zu machen wenn sie sich da vorne alle raiden lassen
Oh nice
Er captcha da captcha
Maastricht
Das war der
Über locations
Oh, die haben wir wieder, da muss ich jetzt aufpassen.
Was ist das für ein Name, wieso?
Auf Leute, gogogog, moin, watt, wie ist der denn gestorben?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, ha!
Oh, wie knapp, oh, wie knapp, wie sich alle mal alle abfarben lassen.
Tai-Elo-Plates, oder wie sagt einer von den, von den, von den englischen Castern immer
Big Slam, Big Slam, ha, ha, ha, ha, okay, das, das irgendwie mit, mit Zen klappt das
sowieso richtig, wenn du die ganze Zeit alleine da stehst, der Rainer geht ab, C9, C9, real
music, oh!
Reinhard!
Oh Reinhard, jetzt wirst du da ran Jungs, jetzt wirst du da ran, alles musst du selbst
machen Leute, geht halt mal ran, ist es denn so schwer?
Na haut rauf Reinhard, haut rauf!
Oh!
das war nicht schlecht
schön gestalt ordentlich was gekillt dass da kein follow-up mehr gekommen ist gut da
über alles kann man auch nicht machen ja um das zu hinten muss man sein bisschen
öfters wieder spielen dann geht das auch weil er fällt ja in einer geraden
linie trifft man das einschätzt gut
reinhardt was machst du da
reinhardt meine hüte bleibt da alter
ein schuss noch
ein schuss
das war das war aufer exzellent das war aufer exzellent
reinhardt rasiert wenn reinhardt industrie mit speed boost dabei hat plus also das ist
das wichtigste das ist das wichtigste dass reinhardt rasieren kann muss danach gibt es
natürlich noch ein paar andere sachen so was wie anna mit nano boost oder so was
hallo ich würde ich würde ich gerne heilen
die sterben wie die fliegen hey links und rechts
jetzt was zum heilen hier
wie lange siehst du heute schweißen hat kannst du echt sagen warum fragst du
ok mehr konstanz machen
heute stolt stolt den scheiß geht halt ran
ne keine chancen keine chancen da geht nix
das war ein paar ganz gute stand plays dabei
sehr sehr nice tire
also eher spätestens 21 euer schluss
ich hoffe das kommt jetzt nicht öfters vor dass das sound so also in krumms back
es ist sonntag abend das müsste eigentlich instant gehen 20 millionen spieler von den
90 millionen aufgehört haben es wäre schön wenn blizzard realistische spielzahlen veröffentlichen
würde 20 millionen verkaufte spieler sagen halt nichts wirklich aus über wie viel aktuell
spielen blizzard hätte auch viel mehr machen können um die leute bei laune zu halten wenn
es halt versucht so zweigleisig zu fahren so quasi competitive leute anzusprechen
ach heute ist ja montag stimmt so ist das halt wenn man montags frei hat aber wenn man
versucht beide anzusprechen quasi casual leute plus competitive und ist alles so halbherzig
meine rennen beide weg würdest du dich auf einen fokussieren jetzt glaube ich bessere
chancen meine ansicht der dinge
das wird nichts winzen ohne ohne support und wir haben die fahrer ich kann es nicht mehr
da oben kann man drauf stehen wusste gar nicht
leute was macht ihr denn nach vorne
das gibt es doch nicht was der ausgerechnet da drin gelandet
meine gott leute wo seid ihr denn alle weg die fahrer war geil oder wieder genau auf dieser
einen mine gelandet ist auf diesem einen auf dieser einen trap
ok
Okay, das war eine beknackte Ult. Ich wusste nicht, dass schon alles tot ist. Das war eine
echt beheuerte, bescheuerte Ult. Aber Mercy killen, wichtigste. Außerdem hatte ich keinen
Charge. Das war kacke. Das hätte man besser machen müssen. Aber deswegen habe ich ja einen
zweiten Account, dass ich so eine Scheiße noch machen kann, ohne dass ich andere Leute das Game
stauer. Haha, du Fett. Lol. Lol. Lol. Haha. Es springt er gegen Türrahmen und dann stirbt
er da oben. Lol. Alter, das ist ja eine totale Rape hier. Aber der Doomfist war geil, wie er
gegen die Tür gesprungen ist. Sogenannte Trollekorn? Nein, das ist kein Trollekorn. Ich habe es
seit Season 4 nicht mehr gespielt richtig. Ich musste mir erst wieder an das Game gewöhnen.
Deswegen habe ich mir einen zweiten Account gemacht. Oder einen dritten, vierten, was
weiß ich. Ja, Sam Fischer, das ist halt so. Dass da der Carry carried, kannst du dich
halt da drauf verlassen. Also das ist Quickplay. Kannst dich auf nichts verlassen. Hallo König
Пошли! Danke!
Danke.
Nein.
Oh Mann!
Das gibt's doch nicht!
Dass ich hier Augen lasse!
Oh Mann!
Das gibt's doch nicht!
Schieße ja, schieße ja!
Du musst da alles selber machen, alles!
Du musst da alles selber machen hier gerade!
Wie ging das nochmal mit dem schneller springen?
Ich kann es, kriegt es nicht mal gebacken gerade.
So?
Irgendwie so, ne?
Den Bogen kriege ich schon wieder raus.
Nein!
Wow!
Na, man kanns ja mal probieren
Wenn ich in diese, ich bin so dumm, dass ich in diese
Falle gelaufen bin, äh
Weil hab ichs gesehen
Irgendwie so, ne? Ging aus
Komm her, komm her
Jetzt wollten sie es aber wissen
Egal, guck mal
Wir haben 99% noch Zeit
Wir könnten mal zur Abwechslung regroupen
Na, was ist denn das hier?
What the fuck?
Komm mal da jetzt mal rein
Okay, ich geh mit, ich geh mit unseren Leuten mit
Was? Ich war auf Deck
Das geht net, ey das
Na gut, ist das Quickplay
Was erwarte ich denn auch?
Was, was erwarte ich denn?
Danke für den Follower
Okay, ich geh jetzt mal rein
Ich versuch die nochmal zu schildern
Was ist das hier denn?
Ist das so, man?
Das kommt hier echt verarscht vorwärts, ne?
Was, ich hab was unlocked?
Für was denn?
Well played?
Was?
Was hab ich denn unlocked?
Oh, oh
Okay, ich geh jetzt mal rein
Habe alles gegeben, naja
Also, ein paar Sachen waren schon ziemlich
beknackt, ja, was ich gemacht habe
Aber ich konnte nicht machen, das war vollkommen
unmöglich, ja
unmöglich
Das ist halt so das typische
Rumgefiede, und das Schlimme ist
dass du das teilweise
noch bis grandmaster siehst nicht so schlimm wie in diesem game aber dieses
reingerenne und sterbe alleine das siehst du bis auf grandmaster hoch und ich
finde das zeigt schon irgendwie das mit dem also eines der vielen sachen die
zeigt das mit dem ranking system stimmt wenn du ein großmeister bist in diesem
spiel da musst du verstanden haben wie das spiel funktioniert sonst wirst du
kein großmeister und du kannst das spiel nicht verstehen wenn du mercy links
klick halten kannst und grandmaster wirst das geht nicht
kein solcher
winston naja das funktioniert einfach nicht
x flame normal schon aber du ist schon anstrengend genug
obwohl es quick plays ansonsten schon
so jetzt mal wieder an die neuen tver fähigkeiten gewöhnen
weil die gegner besser sind gegen die man spielen
und mein kleute wo seid ihr
nix
Ach reine mal reine Rakete, ich vergesse die immer.
ja mehr Kreize und ich ha lol
oh nee ich wollte links klicken
wollte eigentlich ulti klicken, habe ich aber nicht
ich kacknoob bin
oh voll in die rakete gerannt
geht doch nur um spaß
naja klar geht es um spaß, sonst würde man das nicht spielen
aber permanent auf die fresse kriegen ist auch nicht so geil
ok der nächste boost geht rein
der nächste buffen
und bald die fahrer hier wird deleted wenn sie hier lang kommen
moment die ist schon durch
weg
easy easy clap
die neuntich war jetzt echt richtig gut
also ich habe ja gedacht als sie die ändertrug angekündigt haben damals wo ich patchnotes gelesen habe das wird nichts
aber jetzt nachdem ich das erste mal ausprobiert habe ist die echt gut
was ich noch mehr machen muss ist den hier, wenn du an einem vorbei fliegst gibst du ihm immer noch welche mit für 30 damage
nein der farmer zockt keinen, kein overwatch
ich finde es geil wie abhängig es davon ist wenn man seinen stream anmacht jetzt 19.40 viel weniger viewer als vorhin bei 17.17 Uhr
fahren wir halt durch die neustart aber ganz klar sonntag abends logisch
die gehen bestimmt main, nein oh die gehen mit
oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh
konnte hierdurch schießen
oh nee
mit wem, was mit dem router klaus
direkt, jawoll an den nahkampf muss ich mich gewöhnen
das war links, das war links
the place, the place
oh nee
der ana da wusstest du nicht wo du hin sollst
wie lange streamst du heute noch, oh jetzt kommt es hier
spätestens 21 Uhr ist Schluss
krasses play of the game, wahnsinn
70%
ich bin mal abgegangen, get schreckt
du cp, das muss jetzt sein
warum zockst du nicht auf den main, weil der main zu hoch ist
und ich seit season 4 nicht mehr gespielt habe
und ich quasi erst mal 20-30 spiele so halb thrown müsste
nicht absichtlich ja aber einfach weil ich nicht mehr so gut bin
bis ich wieder auf dem richtigen rang bin und das will ich den leuten nicht antun
außerdem das problem ist auch Overwatch hat ja keine möglichkeit
ich wollte grad sagen der Torb
Overwatch hat ja keine möglichkeit zum üben
was spielen wir denn jetzt eigentlich
wir haben kein schild
der main ist wie gesagt seit season 4 gar nichts mehr
wobei doch doch wir haben dings gemacht
ich glaube season 5 nach 10 placements war 3900 oder sowas
aber das war nicht gerechtfertigt das war halt bloß noch weil das interne mma halt sagt
rank den behai master quadmaster ein
was aber nicht mehr stimmt überhaupt nichts mehr sieht man ja auch
sind zwar teilweise immer noch gute plays bei aber
es ist ich sag immer so gute plays ab und zu macht man jeder
gute leute haben machen halt konstant gute plays
so orissa was kann das fisch noch mal
das horse das fährt genau
was ist das für ein kakt umfasst
bestes schild placement bestes schild placement aller zeiten
was ist das hier also mir ist klar dass es quick play ist aber
what the fuck
der ist total dumm
der dumm ist
bis zum monster hunter spielen monster hunter ist eine serie die ist nicht so
meins ich bin nie so richtig mit monster hunter waren achtung achtung
du bleibst auch nicht also nicht funktioniert ich mir das vorgestellt habe
bongo bongo da kommt ja gar nichts da kommt ja gar nichts bongo mäßig
ha ha ha
leute
spielst du bei viewer games zum spaß vielleicht nächste mal ich muss jetzt
erste mal Richtung 25 kommen der schwenk anfangen kann
denn vierer vierer tiefer bombe das ist absichtlich kaum zu schaffen da
müssen da müssen alle mithelfen also das eigene team muss mithelfen vor allem
die gegner müssen mithelfen das einzige wo sowas geplant gut geht ist zum
beispiel diese garten
da über die brücke
direkt richtig recht
jana macht ganz gut
warum killen die noch was eigentlich müssten wir das schon längst
gehen wir mal oben hin leute rennt auch nicht vor
ok sorry max max quick play
also spielst du auch nicht gut
so meinte ich das übrigens vorhin mit diesem man kann man kann die die
schüsse ja schon quasi dahin lenken bevor man die gegner gleich hinzieht
also wie ich mir das gedacht habe
ich bin immer noch vier tage die woche auf der arbeit ja richtig
die weder
ok das zeug macht überhaupt nichts gegen schilder
aber orissa macht spaß
da ein bisschen dran gewöhnt hat
dass wir müssen zum zum punkt
gut
das ist schon ewig her
so
ich mache noch mal ein zwei runden alleine
auf mein konzentrieren kann dass ich das wieder halbwegs auf die reihe kriegt
so nächst du kannst auf die wirklich donate möchtest kannst du auf die profilseite gucken da ist unten ein link also quasi so einer der ersten links auf der seite
aber ich mache twitch ja nicht zum kohle abgreifen so wirklich ich werde auch kein twitch affiliate oder so gedünst machen das einzige wofür ich es gerne machen würde ist für die
emotes
für die emotes würde ich es gerne machen
und subscription zeug meint egal
oooohh 66 eine ordentliche map
was spielen wir denn? attack u66
für die emotes würde ich es machen
komm wir probieren noch mal kurz saria oder mal gleich soldier probieren
immer so um die 200 leute sind die zugucken
da bewerbe ich mich vielleicht weil ich habe ja noch von vor ein paar jahren noch einen kontakt skype du kannst dir ein kleines mal fragen vielleicht gehts dann einfacher aber ich habe es da auch gar nicht so eilig ich habe mir da noch nicht viel gedacht zu gemacht warum wollen die eigentlich da raus
4 3 2 1 attack
escort
gehört
so wir bleiben einfach mal versteckt
keine energie
warum kriege ich keine energie
lieber back geht ab
warum habe ich den nicht gebabbelt
warum habe ich den nicht gebabbelt warum bin ich so langsam in der weile bei sowas
das war eine schöne bubble
echt
das schild war zum beispiel total geknackt
das
Ah ich hab gepusht.
Ja xflame das stimmt, das ist halt Quickplay. Am besten ist halt, du spielst hier irgendwelche
Helden, die sich selbst so ein bisschen supporten können. So irgendwie Soldier ist natürlich ganz
weit vorne mit dabei. Also Torb auch so ein bisschen. So was halt, weil Ana geht auch.
Häh, ich hab schon keinen BOP mehr. Aber gut.
sie
schen Mainly
Schlimmste
cheering
Also ich denke mal noch so 2-3 Streams, dann sind wir 25.
In Kruppe bekommst du mehr XP, ich weiß, ich habe eben auch bis eben in Kruppe gespielt.
Sexerstack, ich will wenigstens bis ich 25 bin wieder so halbwegs die Helden drinnen haben, die gerade angesagt sind und wieder abzudaten, was quasi neue Maps angeht und neue Unfähigkeiten, Änderungen von Helden und sowas.
Das muss bis 25 wieder drin sein.
2CP, wie oft soll man diesen Kackmodus denn heute Abend noch spielen?
Ich hasse diesen Spielmodus, so schrecklich.
Wir brauchen noch einen Support, dann warte ich mal ab.
Mal gucken ob einer Support pickt.
Junkrat muss ich auch noch üben, Junkrat kann ich gar nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Mit Anna wird das wieder schrecklich werden, die rennen alle wild links rum rechts rum vorne rum oben unten hinten.
Du wirst wieder keinen sehen in den Heilen.
Ja Aufwärts macht am meisten Spaß mit 6er Kruppe definitiv definitiv.
D.Va, warum, warum fliegst du?
Was zum Teufel geht hier ab?
Das kann doch nicht sein, dass die schon an der Tod sind.
Was soll ich dir da supporten?
Fuck, ich wollte gerade eine Granate auf die Füße erfen.
Und das Schlimme ist, wir halten das jetzt auch noch.
Absolut planlos, komplett planlos.
Moment, da ist einer auf dem Punkt, kein Jukts.
Nicht genug geheilt, offensichtlich.
Vor allem durch mich.
Pass mal auf jetzt kommt hier, krasse Nate.
Oh knapp, wollte die nicht chasen?
Mein Support macht überhaupt keinen Spaß hier, was ist denn da hinaus?
Ich muss gucken, dass ich wieder gescheit spiele bis 25.
Okay, nein, ihr wollt nicht, dass ich euch sehe.
Was, oh Mann, fuck.
Ich hab ihn nicht gehört.
So, ich Nanoboost jetzt irgendeinen und wechsle dann auf irgendeinen Randomheld.
Ich muss mal Nanoboosten, hallo.
Ach nee, ich rage nicht.
Das kann man nicht rage nennen.
Es ist halt so planlos, hier kannst du dich supporten.
Das funktioniert nicht, bleib stehen.
Go, es ist mir scheißegal, ob da jetzt einer ist.
Das geht ja nix hier, was ist das?
Was?
Ah ja, links, ich hab das Ziel ganz vergessen.
Haha, neuer Held.
Was ist das, links?
Hallo McCree, hallo.
Was ist die, Moment, was ist noch mal die Fähigkeit von Moira, die ult?
Ah, dieser Strahl.
Ich muss wie erst mal die ganzen Fähigkeiten von dem Ding gewöhnen.
Nein, die Falle.
Also was ich finde gut, dass Moira mal ein bisschen komplexerer Support ist.
Das finde ich echt gut.
Mehr konnte ich jetzt nicht machen.
Warum sind die nicht auf dem Punkt?
Sie sind nicht auf dem Punkt gewesen.
Bitte!
Ja, Ana ist auch komplex, ich finde das gut.
Ich bin auch voll überfordert.
Jetzt haben wir keinen Support mehr.
Das ist halt dumm.
Ich geh wieder.
Ja doch, Ana zu spielen ist sau schwer.
Er ist gut zu spielen.
Der will sterben glaube ich, der McCree.
Kannst du deinen Rechtsklick auch machen, Ana?
Was?
Das Teil, äh.
Irgendwie hat der etwas.
Der gefällt mir.
Gut, Rainshield hast du halt.
Ach, Rechtsklick füllt Ana wieder auf.
Muss einem ja auch mal gesagt werden.
Verstehe.
Nein, ich wollte nicht heilen.
Wie viel Damage, Burstdamage macht das Ding nicht.
Verrecken alle Insta, ich sag's euch.
Also ich glaub Meurer wirds.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass wir die sehen in nächster Zeit.
Irgendwelchen Pro-Matches.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht einfach.
Also das ist jetzt glücklicherweise nicht ein weiterer Montz-Button-Support wie Mercy.
Doch Rechtsklick heilt mich selbst hab ich mittlerweile mit gekriegt.
Moment.
Ah, ich hab Ana gespielt am Anfang.
Genau.
Meurer ist in jedem GR-Match mit dabei.
Jupp.
Kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Ich mir gut vorstellen.
Ich find's aber richtig.
Also ich bin der Meinung, man sollte die ganzen, sagen wir mal ein bisschen höher, highskilligeren Helden nicht unbedingt immer nerfen.
Ich finde es sollte sich auszahlen, wenn man eben die schwierigen Helden gut spielt.
Und wenn's geht halt auch nicht nur einen davon.
Weil Overwatch ist halt einfach ein Spiel, der's pro Held jetzt nicht.
Nehmen wir mal sowas aus, mal sowas wie Tracer, Genji aus, das ist schon saumäßig schwer das richtig gut zu spielen.
Aber die meisten Helden sind halt relativ simpel.
Und das skaliert halt eher damit, dass man eben mehrere Helden ganz gut kann.
Als einen, einen Held richtig gut in Overwatch zu können, ist jetzt nicht so das Ding.
Vor allem wenn's, sagen wir mal so, sowas wie Mercy finde ich, kann's eh komplett vergessen.
Das zählt meiner Ansicht nach nicht.
Wenn ich sehe, wie viel Grandmaster Mercy das grundlegende Spielprinzipien nicht verstanden haben und immer noch was sie staggern bis zum geht nicht mehr teilweise.
Aber es müsste mehr Helden in der Richtung geben, deswegen ist Moira da finde ich schon ein richtiger Schritt.
Und man muss sagen, Winston so einfach aussieht, er ist nicht einfach.
Sagen wir übrigens auch die ganzen Koreaner.
Top 10 sind 5 Mercy Malz, das kann schon sein.
Und der Rest ist Tracer, ne?
Nein, falsche Fähigkeit, falsche Fähigkeit.
Das ist wie Rechtsclick.
Nein, ich mach immer den falschen, den falschen Spell.
Gengu.
Warum fiedest du Gengi?
Hör auf, hör auf.
Stopp.
Äh, aber Tracer gibt's auch sau viele gerne. Tracer, das finde ich aber auch gut.
Also alle schreien Nerf Tracer ist blödsinnig.
Nerf Tracer ist blödsinnig.
Tracer ist einer der wenigen Highskill Chars in diesem Game.
Grille oder Kind? Ich glaube eher Kind.
Ups.
Setzt man dann die Meurer Ult am besten ein. Ich meine das Ding heilt ja und macht Damage.
Wobei der Damage gefühlt jetzt nicht total übertrieben ist. Also man kann damit nichts umbürsten.
Ich glaube das Schlimmste an der Meurer Ult für die Gegner ist, dass sie nichts sehen.
Oh ne.
Ich kann da nicht rein. Komm scheiß drauf.
Hätte klappen können. Hätte klappen können.
Zumindest, zumindest einen Take hat man kriegen können.
Die Meurer will nicht geheilt werden. Aber keine Bock.
Wie ist eigentlich die Range von Meurer Rechtsklick?
Falscher. Das ist wirklich nicht so simpel. Jetzt habe ich den Gegner versucht zu heilen anstatt Damage zu machen.
Alles, ja, Joshi, alles gut. Wenig zwanzig Meter. Ja, aber Meurer ist so ein Char, weil man den gut kann. Ich glaube das hat richtig aus, das hat, wie man so sagt, Impact.
Oh, weg hier, weg hier, weg hier.
Du hast da überhaupt keinen Support. Wie geht's da? Immer die gleichen Fragen hier.
Krill. Nein, kein Krill. Kind.
So hitzlos, ey.
Das war ein absolut geknackter Ult. Ich wusste nicht, was ich machen soll. Zumal es hier überhaupt nicht vorwärts geht.
Ey, wir müssen Support spielen.
Wir müssen Support spielen. Das geht nicht anders. Vielleicht Lucio oder so.
Get the point.
Oh my god, you guys are bad.
Ja, guck an. Was ist? Guckt euch das Reingeräte an. Wie soll man das denn supporten?
Ich glaube es ist schon krass. Okay, die lassen sich ums Verrecken nicht heilen. Es geht einfach nicht.
Oh nein, weg, weg, weg, weg. War das knapp, war das knapp. Da kam gleich das Tire an.
So, ich denke mal letztes Match.
Nachhin, so ging es eh auch vorhin auch. Game gestartet, dann kein Bock mehr. Mal gucken, wieviel Bock ich habe, wenn ich 25 bin.
So, ich denke mal, wenn ich 20 bin.
Na auf, Game.
Könnt ihr euch daran erinnern, als es neu war, wo du quasi auf Search gedrückt hast, bevor das Suchefeld oben aufgegangen ist, hast du ein Game gefunden. Kann man bei dir mitmachen? Nee, ich mache jetzt letztes Game.
Ich habe die ganze Zeit in einer Duo geqt, für mehr XP. So, mal ein, zwei Runden alleine spielen.
Zwei Minuten auf Game warten, das ist krass. Vor allem, ey, hallo. In dem Bereich muss es massig Leute geben.
Ja, verkaufte Einheiten sagt halt nicht so viel darüber aus, wieviel wirklich spielen. Ich bin immer noch der Ansicht, wenn man sich komplett auf eine Sache fokussieren würde, also sagen wir mal zum Beispiel auf den Competitive Aspekt, und den quasi mit gesamter Manpower ausbauen würde, sodass es quasi keine Wünsche mehr offen bleiben und das Game sich so einen richtig guten Ruf in der Richtung auch dann bekommt.
Das sollte die Spieler eigentlich am meisten halten. Aber ich meine, die haben selbst Leute, die sich um sowas Gedanken machen. Wobei man sagen muss, naja, wenn man sich Spiele anguckt, die Blizzard letztens halt so rausgehauen hat, also quasi, sagen wir mal, StarCraft 2, Diablo 3 und sowas, das sind auch Sachen, die halt sehr extrem unter Spielerschwund leiden, oder gelitten haben und teilweise kaum noch existent sind. Guckt euch StarCraft 2 an.
Ja, klar, ab und zu gibt es noch ein paar größere Turniere, aber die kriegen dann, was, 15k Zuschauer oder sowas.
Oh, wir haben ein Lucio. Am besten die Leute, die immer sagen, Lucio, der Lucio, der Lucio ist das. Lucio.
Ähm, ich meine eigentlich, ne, brauchen wir einen zweiten Support.
Ihr könnt euch ein bisschen Neura üben. Muss ich wahrscheinlich im Rank dann auch spielen, weil Support, Main und so, ne.
Die haben genug Geld durch Bau, ja, das ist richtig. Ha, gleiche Idee, he.
Direkt.
Reinhardt, komm zurück. Leute, kommt halt zurück.
Was machen die denn da?
Okay, den Shift muss ich mir noch angewöhnen von Moira, den verwende ich noch gar nicht.
Haha, der ist nicht abgerannt. Also, die sind wirklich mutig hier, die Jungs.
Kommt doch mal ein bisschen zurück.
Ich höre rechts was, oder? Hab ich rechts was gehört?
Die müssen jetzt pushen, die werden jetzt richtig hart drauf pushen.
Was ist das für eine Runde?
Ha, der Flamer.
Überflamed im Chat.
Lucio.
Wie spricht man das eigentlich richtig aus?
Das heißt Lucio, oder?
Weil ich meine, der Typ, der Lucio spricht, sagt auch Lucio und das ist ja Brasilianer.
Oder Portugiesisch.
Da, da hatte einer die gleiche Idee wie ich.
Oh, Alter.
Achtung, Achtung.
Sag mal, die wollen jetzt echt wissen, wie sie spawnen können.
Oh, nee.
Da schreit sie, heal me.
War ein bisschen mit dem Voice Chat drauf da.
Echt?
Wenigstens muss man mit Moira jetzt ein bisschen auf die Gegner zielen.
Drop the beat.
Echt, so muss das sein.
Alter, ich hab alles Gold.
Ja, mein Schiff vergesse ich zu oft.
Easy clap, alles Gold.
Nicht, dass es irgendwas aussagen würde.
Rekt hat gerekt.
Edward, eindeutig MEP.
Was wollen sie hier?
Aber Moira macht Bock und ich glaube, wenn man wirklich sich da mal reingedacht hat,
wie das funktioniert und da man ein paar ordentliche Spiele schon drauf hat,
dann rapes sie damit alles weg.
ulous.
the
Mäuler finde ich irgendwie dumm
Oh, da spielt einer Mäuler, das ist schön, da kann ich jetzt mal was anderes spielen
Gucken wir mal, was die Leute wählen
Der Kugelnerv nicht live geht, also dass die Kugel vielleicht ein bisschen kleineren Radius kriegt oder weniger
oft bounced, scheint mir gerechtfertigt zu sein
Aber ich hoffe halt, dass, ich meine Mäuler ist offensichtlich ein Schach
Siehst du ja schon alleine, wie viele Fähigkeiten die hat
Und wie gesagt, ich spiele sie heute auch erst zum ersten Mal
Den ich eindeutig zu einem bisschen höheren Skillklasse zählen würde
Und es wäre blöd, wenn quasi ausgerechnet so ein Held wieder direkt genervt wird
Es braucht mehr Helden, es braucht mehr Helden, sowas in der Richtung
Doomfist, Genji, McCree, Torb, Pharah
Es kann aus, auch kein Ding
Reaper easy, Soldier, gut zu spielen, auch nicht allzu einfach
Sombra, weiß nicht
Tracer, richtig gut
Auch schwer zu spielen, finde ich auch, ein guter Held, passt wunderbar
Bastion, naja gut, Bastion halt
Hanzo, ziemlich inkonsistent
Junkrat, absolut OP
Mei, naja
Torb, situationsbedingt, D.Va OP
Orisa, auch ziemlich gut
Tracer, tolle, Winston, richtig gut
Also es gibt ein paar Helden
Warte mal, wir müssen jetzt erst mal picken
Also
Okay, dann gleich mal einer genießen
Was ist das hier?
Was?
E, E, Max, du vergisst immer dein E
Schon ist er tot, der Reinhardt
Äh, hallo?
Wo ist denn die Widow?
Ist sie hier noch irgendwo?
Voll ins Mehle reingerannt
E-Ax, E-Ax, stimmt nicht
Vier, vier
Vier, der vierte ist das
Ich wollte für ein Steam einmachen
Wunderbar, ganz von vorne
Fuck, das war Over-Extension of Doom
Heal? Heal?
Haben wir überhaupt Heal?
Nein, Hanzo
Rennt in mich rein, äh
Fuck
Spaß, McCree, äh
Wir, Moment
Heißt unser McCree, ne
Heißt unsere Tracer allen Ernstes
Gebärmutter
Hahahaha
Oh Mann, was ein scheiß Name
Hanzo, warum nennt man sich Gebärmutter?
Echt?
Oh, da schießen wir
Achtung, Achtung Leute
Huge, huge
Huge
Wat?
Easy, easy
So muss das sein
Hallo Mr. Tootie
Also wenn die Games so schnell gehen
Sollen wir noch ein Game machen?
Hanzo gesagt 21 Uhr Schluss
Aber nein
Ja
Vergiss nicht deine Raketen
Ja, da muss ich mich noch
Da muss ich echt dran denken
Gebärmutter
Hahahaha
Boah
Mächtige 26%
Aber die war spray
Cool
Brбоengstbit an die ganzen Follows heute wieder
?
Demnick, Bello macht 28, mehr seh ich nicht.
Ah, Rankedness ist in OV Toxic des Todes.
Ah, Eax kann schon sein.
Wenn sie Ranked waren, wenigstens gescheit machen würden.
Hey, wollen wir mal voll Fottem King of the Hill-Seite abspielen?